des images rares inédite visité chaque
année par des millions de touristes
venant des quatre coins du monde le
corcovado l'un des principaux symboles
de rio dé janeiro s'est complètement 10
depuis cinq mois à cause de la pandémie
de covile 19 le site touristique est
fermé pour la première fois en 88 ans le
père omar raposo le responsable du
sanctuaire au de 38 mètres a été obligé
d'organiser ces messes en dehors de la
chapelle du christ rédempteur et puis
l'arrivée du virus au brésil il
s'inquiète pour l'avenir du tourisme à
rio dé janeiro un secteur qui apporte
chaque année plus de 5 milliards de
dollars à la ville merveilleuse
[Musique]
la pandémie a touché fortement le
tourisme à rio et sur toute la planète
d'ailleurs le christ est toujours là
mais tout le secteur touristique autour
de lui a beaucoup souffert
notre économie a besoin des touristes
nous devons mettre aux riches
sans eux la ville est à l'arrêt c'est
pour ça que nous avons besoin de
retourner à la normale mais ce n'est pas
encore le moment les guides touristiques
comme tous les travailleurs non déclarés
au brésil font partie des principales
victimes des conséquences de la pandémie
ces jours là une vingtaine d'entre eux
se sont réunis dans l'un des marchés les
plus populaire de rio pour demander
l'application d'un projet de loi
proposant une aide d'urgence aux guides
touristiques
il n'y a plus de touristes donc on n'a
plus de revenus on nous dit qu'il faut
qu'on change de métier
mais comment je vais changer de métier
en pleine épidémie quand tout est fermé
il n'y a pas de travail et nayda guide à
rio dé janeiro depuis 15 ans a elle
aussi perdu ses revenus du jour au
lendemain comme ses collègues et naïda a
été obligé de se réinventer
pas toujours facile dans un contexte de
crise sanitaire et économique pour
continuer à payer ses factures à la
décidé de vendre des gâteaux et des
biscuits à domicile et dans les marchés
je suis resté sans travail pendant
quatre mois nous les guides
on a été les premiers touchés et on n'a
aucune perspective de changement
le gouvernement nous a tourné le dos
c'est tellement triste
le tourisme de luxe n'a pas été plus
épargnée par la pandémie à rio dé
janeiro 57 hôtels ont fermé leurs portes
et situé sur la plage d'ipanema
le célèbre hôtel face à no 1 des plus
chics de la ville a été obligé d'annuler
toutes les réservations pendant plus de
trois mois
avec l'assouplissement des règles de
confinement l'établissement a pu rouvrir
ses portes tout en limitant sa capacité
d'occupation de 50% et en respectant une
série de précautions sanitaires
on a mis toutes nos serviettes dans des
sacs plastiques
il n'y a plus de buffet pour le petit
déjeuner quand nous avons vu que cette
fournée de toucher le tourisme cela nous
a fait peur mais nous les habitants de
rio
nous sommes toujours optimistes depuis
l'arrivée du covic 19 au brésil le
secteur du tourisme a déjà accumulé des
pertes de plus de 17 milliards de
dollars
on estime qu'au moins trois cent mille
personnes auraient perdu leur emploi
dans le secteur